what do you have
planned in the future after this sort of
pandemic thing clears out what
what have you been doing what's your
schedule like what do you what does your
day consist of
right witch pandemic porn or corona oh
both
i don't know i mean obviously you said
be at a beach yeah sorry
you were living in l.a right i'm
actually i'm kind of going back and
forth between
sweden la and actually thailand
okay yes i've spent my winters in
thailand for the last
maybe five years or so for five years
really
yes wow what have you seen
in thailand yeah um although it's been
like
mainly like uh i'm combining it with
like work like from
from afar like distance work and then
vacation
but obviously uh thailand is very
you know with uh uh it's very extensive
um and so you you'll see
um yeah you'll see sexpires all over
um when it comes to like in these
specific brothel areas
and they won't be all um
i mean yeah you're gonna see different
uh ages
and whatever but it's obviously there's
a lot of like tourists but there's also
a lot of like thai men really buying sex
from
from women in prostitution in in
thailand
thailand's a lot like vegas in a way
right three
when it comes to like sex work and
prostitution thailand is very similar to
las vegas is that right
for sure yes for sure do you think
that's mainly because of the tourism
there
i mean it absolutely has something to do
with it
absolutely like um yeah like hundreds of
thousands of people will go to thailand
even just from sweden every year
to you know do vacation um
so that obviously affects um the the
amount of brothels available
but as i was saying it's also important
to know that
it is a lot of thai men as well who are
actually visiting uh these brothels and
it's the same you see the same in india
it's not only tourists it's really a lot
of indian men as well going to brothels
so
really yeah so it's it's a it's a
domestic problem
as well as an international um problem
and are you so are you talking to people
there like
compared to people in the different
places you go to have you ever talked to
anybody in thailand
not in thailand actually i've kind of
stayed clear because i'm just like i
need some vacation
oh yeah yeah um
so no but i've met um throughout these
years that i work with this issue i met
maybe
yeah if i'm not gonna exaggerate maybe
i'm at like 400 people in prostitution
over the years
wow men and women and transgender people
and i've met uh sex buyers and
people convicted of sex offending you
know crimes and
um in various countries in austria
germany sweden norway yeah
the list goes on and
yeah and so yeah so what would i do
after
so you interviewed you interviewed pete
like sex offenders that were in prisons
yeah yes not not not officially
interviewing but i've done volunteer
work for years
okay did you ever actually have
conversations with any of them or
yeah that's that's what you do when you
do so
yes i mean i've had hundreds of
conversations
uh with people convicted of the most
you know awful things you can't i mean
you can't even imagine and i rarely
read their files or anything i was very
like
yeah just to kind of meet the person
you know what i mean instead of the
offender
but they would they would tell me a lot
of them would tell me and would share
what their conviction
was for and some wouldn't um
but yeah there are some pretty um
tough stories and it's also
i mean i would really say because that
also hit me when i because i did
like years of uh volunteer work in um in
different
uh prostitution like red light areas
yeah and meeting people in prostitution
and then exchanging that for prison work
what i really saw and it kind of shook
me like what i really saw was the
similarities
to when it comes to the background
stories
and you kind of saw like okay like none
of you
grew up the way you deserve to grow up
you know
and then things happen and you know
your life took a turn and you made bad
choices
and yeah i'm not excusing anything
because it's so awful
uh the things that that you know a sex
offender does
obviously it's it's horrible but i would
also say that i have also i've had some
really great experiences when it comes
to meeting them because i've really seen
the person behind it again not to excuse
anything but just to kind of add to it
um the the childhood trauma and the
things that has happened to
to a lot of people yeah i think the the
prison term for the sex offenders is i
think everybody in prison just calls
them chomos
which is short for child molesters yeah
so they think if you're in there for a
sex crime you're automatically a child
molester yeah
is that was that what you noticed it was
most of it with like underage type stuff
i mean not i would say that too
of course um it would be anything it
would be anything from rape
to because in sweden um you combined if
you are convicted of a
um if let's say you have beaten up your
partner
then you will be put in the same prison
as someone who has committed a rape
okay so it would be anything on that
spectra really okay
yeah yeah how long have you lived in
sweden again
oh since okay let's see how long have i
been i'm
13 years i think going on 14 i think
yeah okay because that that part of the
world
norway sweden denmark they're way more
open sexually than people in america
most of america is made up of
people who are very insecure i think is
actually compared to that part of the
world
i think you're doing a great job thank
you i appreciate
it what's the future of your company
and what kind of plans you guys have for
the next year next few years
um i'm really as i said i'm so in love
with la
so i'm like i have to be there um
and wow that's so funny what
is that the only part of the united
states you've been to no i've been to
dc okay and vegas
bt vegas nla and l.a
okay so i need to i need to do
uh a road trip i feel yeah
yes definitely do a road trip yeah a
coastal road trip
i mean obviously through the middle of
the country you'll see some really
interesting [ __ ] too
right but along like the east coast
there's some there's some amazing places
on the east coast
including florida including florida yeah
miami
miami is a place you have to go to i
have to go to it it's like another
country
it is i feel like it's like
there's so many countries within the us
yeah definitely yeah
yeah but when you're in miami
you honestly feel like you're on another
continent
it's it feels so isolated from anything
else well i guess compared to florida
because nothing else in florida is like
miami
right
i have to go but yeah la i'm not a big
fan of la i'm not really a big fan of it
i love san diego i love like up north
california but
la just seems like so much traffic you
know
so much like the people are so
superficial and fake there i feel like
not everybody but for the most part i
think i've been so lucky because that's
everybody keeps telling me that like
whenever i go there it's just like
everybody is like oh beware like you
know
me and i'm like i haven't seen that yet
i'm
really we're surprised i don't know but
it's yeah i'm lucky
everybody has been so genuine and yeah
um yes
i've made friends like real friends and
yes for sure
they'll expose themselves for who they
really are don't
it's coming you know when that happens
yeah no i think like we really want to
go towards like being more
um yeah once corona is gone
um we could be more uh present i think
uh in l.a i really want to study in the
us some more
i'd love to study perhaps i don't know
i've looked into studying law
at ucla i've looked into some programs
at harvard but that's
um i wouldn't want to be in boston so i
had to i you know i have to look at some
programs that they have that you can do
um from home basically like you don't
have to be on campus all the time yeah
so i'm like looking into different
studying options
and to see um yeah
i got a good feeling about the future i
know i think it's gonna you know they're
gonna happen
so and i see like when it comes to this
this year i really see like
people are opening up like people are
talking about it more and more and
um just checking my dms every day i'm
like
like okay there's this guy from iran or
there's this guy from saudi arabia or
there's this girl from australia you
know what i mean it's like
all over so it's so i think people are
hungry for a conversation on porn